Transcription: Stéphane Roger
Relecteur: Morgane Quilfen
J'ai envie d'aller m'installer
sur la planète Mars,
et d'y vivre pour le restant de mes jours.
Parce que, quand j'étais petite fille,
je voulais visiter
tous les mondes de l'univers.
Parce que la Terre
est le berceau de l'humanité
mais qu'on ne passe pas toute sa vie
dans un berceau.
Parce qu'aucun être humain
n'a encore jamais vu une autre planète
de ses propres yeux,
Parce que je ne suis pas très optimiste
quant à la survie à court,
moyen et long termes de l'humanité.
et que je voudrais savoir
si nous pouvons survivre
dans un environnement extrêmement hostile.
Parce que la planète Mars
peut permettre de répondre
à certaines questions comme :
pourquoi la vie est apparue sur Terre ?
Et que je voudrais beaucoup participer
à ce genre de recherche scientifique.
Parce que ça me passionne,
parce que ça me fascine,
parce que j'en ai envie.
Mais oui, après tout,
quelle meilleure réponse que l'envie
pour justifier un choix ?
Et pourquoi vous êtes venus ici,
vous, ce soir?
Parce que vous en aviez envie, non?
J'espère...
Je ne sais pas mais,
quand on a un choix à faire,
en général on prend l'option
qui nous plaît le plus.
Personne au restaurant ne se dit :
j'ai bien envie d'une entrecôte,
alors mettez-moi la salade,
ce sera parfait.
Non, personne, jamais.
Alors vous allez prendre l'entrecôte,
parce que vous en avez envie.
Mais il y aura toujours quelqu'un
pour vous dire :
« Oui mais attention,
tu as déjà mangé de la viande rouge hier,
tu sais, ça ne se fait pas. »
Ça ne se fait pas.
Quand j'étais ado, comme beaucoup d'ados,
j'écrivais des chansons et des poèmes.
J’aimais particulièrement
les sonnets et les alexandrins
et, pour les chansons,
j’essayais d’utiliser un vocabulaire
et des tournures de phrases
un peu élaborés.
Quelques années plus tard,
je cherche un job
pour financer mes études.
Je réponds à l’annonce d’un vieux monsieur
qui cherche une aide administrative.
Je me présente chez lui
et, au cours de la conversation,
j’apprends qu’il est président
d’une association de poètes.
Je lui dis que moi aussi
j’écris des poèmes.
Il me demande quel genre de poèmes.
Je lui réponds que j’aime particulièrement
les sonnets et les alexandrins.
Et là, il a un petit rire très méprisant,
très blessant, et il me dit :
« Ça ne se fait plus ma petite,
on n’écrit plus de sonnets
ni d’alexandrins depuis très longtemps. »
Je ne décroche pas le job
et j’arrête d’écrire des poèmes.
Peu de temps après,
je me présente au concours d’entrée
de l’école d’auteurs-compositeurs
d’Alice Dona.
Je m’installe au piano
et j’interprète de mon mieux, évidemment,
la chanson que j’ai composée
et que j’ai écrite de manière
un peu élaborée.
Je joue le dernier accord et là
un silence un peu trop long à mon goût
s’installe.
Alice Dona finit par prendre la parole
et me pose cette simple question :
« Est-ce que vous vous sentez bien
dans votre époque ? »
(Rires)
Oui, voilà, je suis complètement
déstabilisée.
Du coup, elle s’explique :
« Non mais parce qu'on dirait
que vous parlez comme
dans « Les liaisons dangereuses ».
Ça ne se fait plus, on n’écrit plus
de paroles de chansons comme ça. »
Je suis recalée et j’arrête d’écrire
des chansons.
Quelques années plus tard,
Patrick Poivre d’Arvor
organise un concours littéraire
pour fêter les 20 ans de son émission
« Vol de nuit ».
Il faut écrire un texte
sur un personnage de la littérature
qui nous a marqué.
Je me souviens du vieux monsieur poète,
je me souviens d’Alice Dona,
j’essaie donc d’écrire un texte
sur un personnage qui m’a plu.
Mais bon enfin voilà, sans plus en fait.
Et je n’y arrive pas.
Tout ce que je fais est mauvais,
je jette, je ne sais pas,
vingt brouillons.
Ça me saoule et je finis par abandonner.
Quelques semaines se passent, et puis
le jour de la fermeture du concours,
je ressens le besoin d’écrire
ce que j’avais dans les tripes
depuis le début.
J’ouvre un document Word,
30 minutes plus tard mon texte était prêt.
Je le relis à peine et je l’envoie.
J’ai gagné le concours.
Je l’ai gagné avec un texte sur le vicomte
de Valmont des Liaisons Dangereuses
que j’ai écrit entièrement en alexandrins.
(Applaudissements)
Ces chers alexandrins
qui me tiennent à cœur.
Que je veux lire entendre
et écrire à toute heure.
C’est comme de la musique,
j’adore le rythme que ça dégage.
Ça me parle, ça me touche.
Mais au fond, qui m’empêche
d’écrire des alexandrins ?
Le vieux monsieur poète et Alice Dona sont
des personnes tout à fait respectables
et reconnues par leurs pairs.
Mais moi je suis parfaitement libre
d’écrire ce que j’ai envie d’écrire.
Cette histoire m’a enseigné deux choses.
La première c’est que décider
de rester fidèle à soi-même,
c’est prendre le risque de ne pas être
en adéquation avec ce qui se fait.
La deuxième c’est que ce risque
est toujours payant.
Car même si
j’avais perdu le concours,
de toute façon j’avais besoin d’écrire
ce texte comme je le ressentais.
Parce qu’il me ressemblait,
parce qu’il était moi.
Parce qu’il était ce qui se faisait
pour moi.
Et parce que j’ai fini par comprendre,
qu’au fond,
personne ne peut m’empêcher
de faire ce que j’avais envie de faire.
Alors, faire ce qui ne se fait pas,
quand on participe
à un concours littéraire, c’est une chose
Quand il s’agit de choix plus importants,
c’en est une autre.
Aller à contre-courant de ce qui se fait
demande beaucoup plus de travail
et beaucoup plus d’énergie
que d’emprunter des voies
qui sont déjà toutes tracées.
Enfin c’est vrai, tous ici,
au moins une fois dans notre vie,
on a abandonné un rêve, un projet,
cette jolie veste jaune canari
ou un texto pour proposer un verre
à une personne parce qu’on avait peur,
parce qu’on pensait que c’était impossible
ou que ça ne se faisait pas.
Mais au fond qui nous empêche de faire
ce qu’on a envie de faire ?
Le plus souvent, la réponse
à cette question c’est nous-même.
Alors oui, quand il s’agit de projets,
quand il s’agit de choix,
quand il s’agit d’ambitions
très personnelles,
ça peut faire peur,
ça peut être compliqué aussi.
Les autres peuvent penser
que ce n’est pas sérieux
et donc qu’on est fou
ou que ça ne se fait pas. Et alors ?
Réussir à faire ce qu’on a envie de faire
n’est pas toujours impossible.
Moi, dans mon entourage, il y a des gens
qui me le prouvent tous les jours.
Cette copine à moi par exemple,
qui a toujours rêvé d’être musicienne,
qui est monteuse pour la télévision,
mais qui part dans trois jours
s’installer en Norvège avec son mec
pour ouvrir une école de musique
et qui sort son premier album
à la rentrée de septembre.
Cet autre ami qui a finalement
fait le choix de divorcer
parce qu’il s’est rendu compte que
ses enfants avaient plus besoin
d’un papa séparé qui soit bien
dans ses baskets
plutôt qu’un papa toujours marié
mais qui n’arrivait plus à être lui-même
dans cette relation.
Ou cet autre ami
qui propose un texte à un grand éditeur,
qui lui demande s’il n’a pas autre chose,
qui lui répond : « Si si bien sûr »,
alors qu’il n’a rien.
Et qui, deux ans plus tard est traduit
dans neuf langues.
Et moi, qui voulais visiter
tous les mondes de l’univers
quand j’étais petite fille,
et qui suit maintenant candidate
pour un aller simple vers Mars.
Alors ce n’est pas commun,
je vous l’accorde.
Du coup je fais face à un peu
tous les types de détracteurs.
Il y a ceux qui savent :
« C’est impossible,
ça ne se fera jamais ».
Peut-être. Mais personne n’en sait rien.
Et puis on disait déjà ça pour la lune.
Et il y a toujours des gens pour dire
qu’on ne l’a jamais fait.
Il y a ceux qui ricanent
et qui me prennent pour une débile :
« Mais tu es au courant qu’il n’y a pas
de billet retour ?
– Oui je suis au courant, oui.
– Ah mais alors donc
ça ne te fait pas peur ?
– Si, si ça me fait peur. »
Mais la peur est un moyen, pas un frein.
Et il y a ceux qui s’énervent,
ça c’est mes préférés :
« Mais tu es complètement folle !
C’est du suicide !
Enfin mais tu vas mourir ! »
Oui, oui je vais mourir, mais vous aussi.
C’est fou, c’est impossible,
ça fait peur, bouh.
J’ai été la première en fait
à me dire tout ça
et j’ai bien failli ne pas m’inscrire
pour toutes ces raisons.
Mais j’ai fini par le faire parce que
j’en avais envie
et parce que j’ai fini par comprendre
que j’étais la seule
qui m’empêchait de le faire.
Alors je me suis inscrite
comme 202 585 autres candidats
à travers le monde
à un projet qui s’appelle Mars One
et qui envisage sérieusement
d’établir une base humaine permanente
sur la planète Mars.
Aujourd’hui il ne reste que 705 candidats
toujours en lice et j’en fais partie.
Et ce n’était pas gagné.
Je veux dire que quand je suis née,
aucune bonne fée ne s’est penchée
sur mon berceau et m’a dit :
« Alors toi, plus tard, tu seras
comédienne, auteure, chroniqueuse,
tu te sentiras vachement bien
dans ton époque
donc tu gagneras un concours littéraire
en 2008 avec des alexandrins
et peut-être que tu mourras
très vieille sur Mars. »
Non, personne n’a dit ça. Jamais.
Non j’ai fait comme tout le monde.
Quand je suis née, mes proches
autour de moi
ont commencé à tirer des plans
sur la comète :
« Quand elle sera grande… »
Ben voilà, j’ai 30 ans, je mesure 1m57.
Voilà pourquoi il ne faut jamais
tirer de plans sur la comète.
Donc moi j’ai choisi de viser Mars.
Mars.
C’est un environnement
extrêmement hostile, Mars.
C’est une planète qui se trouve
à plusieurs dizaines de millions
de kilomètres.
Il fait -63°C en moyenne.
L’atmosphère est composée à 95% de CO2.
Il n’y a pas d’eau liquide.
On n’y a trouvé aucune trace de vie
et elle est bombardée en permanence
par des rayons cosmiques.
Est-ce que je fais une erreur ?
Est-ce que c’est un mauvais choix ?
Mais au fond, finalement,
est-ce que j’en ai vraiment envie ?
A chaque grande décision que nous avons
à prendre dans notre vie,
cette question se pose.
Et c’est souvent très difficile
d’y voir clair.
Mais j’ai vécu une autre expérience
qui m’a beaucoup appris.
J’ai toujours voulu être comédienne
mais mes parents
m’ont toujours vue journaliste.
Ils ont donc accepté de financer
mon école de comédie musicale
à condition que je reprenne
de vraies études
pour avoir un vrai diplôme.
Une fois formée en chant,
en danse et en théâtre,
je suis donc retournée à la fac.
Et pour la 5ème année,
j’ai décidé de faire un master
de journalisme.
C’était un master en alternance,
c’était un master professionnel,
donc en alternance,
et il fallait que je trouve
un contrat d’apprentissage.
Après cinq mois de recherches intensives,
je ne trouvais toujours rien.
Et puis un soir de novembre,
il s’est passé exactement la même chose
que le jour de la fermeture du concours
de « Vol de nuit ».
De manière totalement irréfléchie
et incontrôlée,
j’ai ouvert un document Word et,
30 min plus tard,
j’avais écrit et mis en forme
mon CV court métrage
façon Amélie Poulain.
7 jours après, il était en ligne,
3 mois plus tard,
il avait fait le tour du web
et des médias de France et d’ailleurs
et 5 ans après,
il est toujours cité en exemple.
Je ne vous expose pas crânement
un exploit extraordinaire,
loin de là,
car c’était un échec.
Je n’ai jamais trouvé
mon contrat d’apprentissage.
Pourquoi ?
Cette question m’a obsédée
pendant des années.
Mais des années.
Et puis il n’y a pas si longtemps,
je l’ai revisionnée.
On m’y voit m'amuser
à jouer mon propre rôle
avec beaucoup d’autodérision,
de caricature.
On m’y entend faire la voix off
à la manière d’André Dussolier,
on y voit des extraits de spectacles
auxquels j’ai participés.
Mais jamais, à aucun moment,
je ne parle de journalisme.
Je n’ai donc jamais trouvé
mon contrat d’apprentissage,
mais deux ans plus tard,
ce CV-vidéo m’a permis de décrocher
un job en or à la télévision,
où j’ai fait des tas de choses
dont jouer la comédie.
Écrire trois pages d’alexandrins,
c’est beaucoup de travail et d’énergie.
Reprendre des études de journalisme,
Réaliser un court métrage,
c’est beaucoup de travail et d’énergie.
Et faire partie des 705 candidats restant
pour un aller simple vers Mars,
c’est beaucoup de travail et d’énergie.
Alors pourquoi certaines choses
fonctionnent et d’autres pas ?
Je ne suis pas journaliste,
je l’ai toujours su.
Je ne pouvais pas devenir journaliste
parce que je ne pouvais pas devenir
ce que je ne suis pas.
En revanche, je ne sais pas vous
mais moi je me sens bien là,
sur scène, a vous raconter des histoires.
Et c’est la même chose devant un micro
ou devant une caméra.
Je me rends compte que je suis
sur un tapis rond et rouge,
on dirait que je suis sur Mars,
sur scène.
C’est comme si c’était là,
ma place dans l’univers.
Et c’est génial.
On ne peut pas lutter contre soi-même.
On ne peut pas se mentir,
en tout cas pas longtemps
ni sans dommages.
Nous devons donc faire les choix
qui sont les nôtres,
même si ça ne se fait pas.
Et vous savez ce qui est encore
plus jouissif pour moi
que de faire ce qui ne se fait pas,
c’est de faire
ce qui ne s’est encore jamais fait.
J’ai l’univers dans mon ADN.
Je suis comédienne parce que
j’aime tellement la vie
que je veux en vivre plusieurs à la fois.
Je suis auteure et je suis chroniqueuse
parce que j’aime raconter des histoires.
Et je ne sais pas si je raconterai
la suite de celle-ci depuis Mars
mais si je vais jusqu’au bout
de l’aventure,
alors Mars me permettra de visiter
un des autres mondes de l’univers.
Mars me permettra
de vivre une deuxième vie.
de raconter une histoire,
des histoires inédites dans toute
l’histoire de toutes les civilisations.
Et surtout je compte bien raconter
les premières impressions
des premiers pas sur le sol martien,
même si ce ne sont pas les miens,
sous la forme d’un sonnet en alexandrins.
Ça ne se fait pas, oui, je sais.
Mais j’en ai envie, alors je le ferai.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)